[Music]
that's going to be a complicated
Insurance
claim he fell straight over do not
interfere with wild animals hello I'm Dr
Anne Jones the ABC's nature
nerd today we're looking at videos of
dangerous neighborhood
animals some of them might not be what
you
expect God Dam it from out Fury and
feathery friends just being
jerks to exotic pets that snap and go
Rogue and someone who survived a scary
encounter with an
alligator animal dangers lookt closer
than you might think we've searched for
the best viral videos of our five
deadliest
Neighbors reptiles come in all sorts of
shapes and sizes and they almost always
elicit a respon of fear from us so it
can be easy to imagine that these
ancient creatures are out there scheming
to kill
[Music]
us no we got trouble in here uhoh we
want it's trying to death roll
her and alligator and crocodiles do a
thing called a death roll and this is
where they grab onto the prey and
basically spin them around like a
centrifuge in the water and that's what
it did it took her on a hole at least
1360 but she stayed so calm I can't
believe
it okay I'm intrigued as to how they're
actually going to do this a lion has a
bite force of something like 600 lb per
square in and a human 120 lb the bite
force that an alligator has is 2 to
3,000 lb per square in that's intense
probably one of the strongest bites in
the
world oh now what what's that guy going
to do he's just going to ride the
alligator around for the rest of his
life
no that
tail she's
dead wow okay number one I need to
interview the kids because that's going
to be a story that they'll remember the
rest of their
life I spoke with someone who survived a
scary encounter with an
alligator what ended up happening was
was that two objects myself and the
alligator were swimming towards each
other so the impact of this large
reptile in my skull was the first impact
and that's what crushed my temporal
loobe and then after the impact then it
opened its mouth and then I went
completely inside of it the bite was the
cause of most of the injury is what is
what crushed my jaw and separated in
like four different ways like opening an
alligator's mouth especially that big
it's not an easy task it's not something
that you do right as I grabed um I was
just kind of I was attempting obviously
to open its mouth it goes into this
tonic immobility face uh the perfect
time for me to swim from where we're at
to the dock and when I got out of the
dock that I remember looking down and
seeing this giant tail I mean the list
of the actual injuries I was reading it
and it's it's like two pages long it was
a total of almost a 100 Staples to close
the laceration in the front of my face
and in the back of my head and then my
jaw had completely dislocated from its
hinges I understand where they kind of
uh live and I respect them there's
really no bad feelings uh about
them all right
snakies hi baby girl that is a big
python look at it can it come out
oh oh he okay well should I continue
filming yes you should always continue
filming don't you know anything about
the
internet wow that's gone the full
Wy okay no I need to get it's bitten her
to get an initial grasp and then quick
as anything it wrapped itself around her
arm and it's constricting as strong as
it possibly can
that is a big python you can see the
muscles tensing on that animal wow can
we see if we can get her off of my arm
luckily for this lady pythons are not
venomous it kills by constricting and
that's exactly what this snake has tried
to do to this
lady no no honey teeth python got 80 to
200 teeth and the teeth aren't shaped
like ours in just one line they're
shaped in several lines across the mouth
so that when they bite into the prey
you've got basically 100% chance of
getting
snagged oh now it's gone to the
leg look at her hand going like a
different color ooh she's
bleeding it's
brutal all right
so yes have a snake for a pit they say
[Music]
Jesus that's huge it's not the place
that you really want to come across an
Asian water monitor where you're in the
supermarket just need some cough
medicine look at the climbing they've
got really good
claws you going to pay for that
mate it's got these big long sharp
curved claws that enable it to pull all
of its heft up into
trees he wants a
slurpie they can grow up to 3 m long and
they are scary they're found in South
and Southeast Asia and they are second
only in size to the kodo dragon those
really big scary
ones and as is polite in monitor Society
let them finish their shopping
[Music]
first is that a snake in his hand or a
lanyard take me to the hospital those
door cameras have provided the internet
with so much gold I think that probably
what was happening was the snake was
sitting on top of the wire door and
you've given it a fright and it's
reacted to defend itself in Australia
there's something like two deaths a year
from snake bites taken internationally
snake bites are actually a really big
public health issue something like 5.4
million snake bites occur every single
year but out of those only 2.7 million
uh in venations so a snake can bite
defensively without actually injecting
it Venom into
you doesn't really want to expend its
venom on someone as useless as you to
eat useless to eat as
you a snake that's not just a snake
that's a Whopper that is a tubster of a
snake is that a python snake pythons
tree snakes they have
incredible muscles all the way along
their body they can use their back third
of their body in order to grip and
extend their body like we saw this snake
doing you know it was trying to bridge
between the house and the tree and it
can basically use its muscles like a
bridge coming down watch out wa that is
a big one
thp I mean I would scream as
well Dad like that that's what I'd
scream
like they may have a hard time
slithering their way into our hearts but
reptiles are impressive animals and they
deserve to be treated with caution but
also with respect and sometimes even
[Music]
awe cat videos have been filling up the
internet ever since it existed and they
have this wonderful mix of being aloof
and being super cute as well as being
conspirator really evil if they want to
so are these lovable jerks actually
trying to do us
harm the classic
internet just having our
dinner
who that was a massive spr right our
cat's scared of cucumbers let's get to
the bottom of it now there's some
conjecture out there that a long thin
thing could be like a predator it could
be a Liz it could be a
snake what you got to imagine is that
they're like a superhero on four legs
they have amazing senses their waties
are good their ear holes are awesome
their eyes are fantastic they've got
whiskers they can sense all around them
and then all of a sudden this cucumber
appears out of nowhere they've never had
anything appear out of nowhere that's
why they
jump should we continue to scare hat for
our enjoyment no we probably shouldn't
you're right ethically no but for
internet points
yes oh
no
wa oh God they're like rebounding off
every surface as if it's like a pinball
machine everybody's angry with each
other cuz none of them know what
happened oh you even get a good back
arch and fluffy tail at the end
cats have incredibly fast reflexes
they're made up almost entirely of fast
twitch fibers they're sprinters a
domestic cat can jump up to nine times
its own body height so that would be
like the equivalent of me being able to
just jump straight up onto like the
third story of a building they have
incredibly flexible spines they can bend
every which way and that means that they
can parkour off like two surfaces at
once I told you they were superhero
[Music]
is that a pigeon she's going to Turf it
oh you want to gently just TOS it why is
she asking it to fly
backwards cat got the pigeon the cat's
got it nailed it the first chance it got
I mean to be fair they gave that cat
every advantage in that situation it's
like look at what we've got are you
going to eat this look at it it can't
fly very
well cats are incredible Hunters like
incredible hunters in Australia pet cats
are thought to kill 390 million native
animals a year this includes mammals
birds and reptiles I can hear you typing
your next comment it says my cat doesn't
hunt because it never brings anything
home and I'm sorry to say that that's
probably because your cat doesn't like
you very
much there was a study out of America
that stated that about a quarter of all
prey items were bought home to the owner
and the rest of them were either
consumed out there in the big wide world
or just killed and left that's cats for
you oh
[Music]
ctin
who I see the jump on that
thing that launched attack is pretty
amazing it jumped at least three times
its own height to attack
him this guy isn't a friend of these
cats he's a friend of their owner and
he's coming to clean up their
poops so number one maybe the cat is
offended that he's playing with the
poops number two it's an intruder and
Cat will actually defend themselves and
their
area domestic cats are formidable
animals they've got front and back claws
they spend a lot of time looking after
them and making sure that they're
absolutely perfect murder
mittens number three the pants were
frankly
offensive in general Cats won't attack
for no reason but they can form you know
some testy relationships with individual
ual and if you're on the receiving end
of that it may mean that your presence
alone will aggravate a cat holy [__]
sorry all right we got a kid on a bike
on
[Music]
a frankly looks a little bit too big for
the bike not
judging oh dog dog with tail up and
erect dog on a
mission
oh yeah caddy oh look at it chased it
away and see that dog which you know
ostensibly could kill a cat quite easily
was [__] scared of that cat that's cuz
cats are scary they also can be loyal
and protective and that's what we're
seeing from this cat the dog has come at
the child the cat was having none of
that the cat runs over and sees the dog
off using SC scare attack it comes in
sideways makes itself look bigger it's
got the big tail puffed out it was using
its claws and coming at the dog and
anyone who's been on the receiving end
of a cat claw knows that ouch the dog
takes off the cat makes sure that it's
gone and all of this is to say that cats
actually do have some attachment to
their
owners there's no doubt that cats will
continue to entertain us with their
acrobatic
skills and their sometimes complex and
quirky
behaviors got
[Music]
it there's a certain Grace and Power
about horses and donkeys they have a
sort of stoic indifference to the world
that I love but when does horsing around
actually end up being
dangerous
[Music]
a is a tail gone at the same
time they're so adorable I mean it's
something about the size of the ears
compared to the size of the animal like
their ears are just so
big this donkey is demonstrating one of
the things that makes donkeys unique
it's braing the he [__] what it's doing
is actually making sounds on the exhale
and the inhale so it's
going and making sounds both in and out
whereas a horse when it wants to Nay
just is on the
exhale and they use this braing for
everything they're angry they're hungry
when they see a friend when they're
horny they're all just going to he I
think is that the right way he he oh
actually it's the other way
[Music]
[__] look at it so fluffy is that a baby
or is that like a miniature
donkey a I'm coming I'm coming here I
come I can hear
you they're such personable sort of
creatures aren't they and it's really
funny that donkeys are sort of referred
to as being idiots cuz it's really not
the case at all it's not like they're
Einstein or anything but they're
actually pretty smart and they form
really strong social bonds so they will
form a pair bond with an individual like
their special friend and sometimes those
pair bonds can go into species so
sometimes the pair bond can be between a
donkey and a human and it means that
when they're separated from each other
the donkey will use all of its powers
intellectual and otherwise to get back
to its friend and it's going to do
things like climb over walls and go
through
brambles look I said they were smart but
you know everyone has their moments I
[Music]
I no you're so
pretty
wa I mean to be fair that gave me a
little fright as well get it Joy get it
Joy no don't get it get it get it get it
you're going to get your ass
now went through the fence at the end
quite dangerous that snaap and turtle
tried to give that horse what
for horses are really curious animals
but they also are prey to other animals
and that means they've got a really
highly developed flight or fight
response when they get a fright
one of the weapons that horses have is
their kick which is incredibly fast and
incredibly strong a horse's kick goes as
quick as 320 km an hour in fact there
was a case of a man who got kicked in
the chest by a horse and he actually
went into cardiac arrest because of it
horses will break your
heart oh look at this picturesque
Mountain scene with um wild horses wild
they're not wild
uhoh nope nope
nope oh yeah oh yeah this is a classic
case of the human not knowing how to
interpret horse communication the horse
gave clear signs to that human to not
approach as soon as he started to come
towards it with his hand out the horse
raised its head up and it put its ears
back and and this really aggressive tail
flip that really really obviously tells
you that they're angry and he didn't
listen so he got beaten that's what
happens when you approach animals I mean
horses can bite strong enough to break
bones if they want to and you need to
give it some personal
space I don't know what they're putting
water on it
[Music]
for and it's got a cat in it it's like
favorite oh
hey
oh
a how's the core strength on that cat
[Music]
though horses explore a lot with their
lips they're actually really sensitive
and gorgeously velvety if you ever get
close to them they've actually got
really coarse little whiskers and they
function like a cat's whiskers they
receive sensory information and send it
straight up to the brain and one of the
reasons why they actually need to have
this sensory apparatus at the end of
their muzzle is because the way their
eyes are placed means that they really
can't see what's directly in front of
them on the
ground I'm not sure that the horse was
actually being mean there I think it was
just exploring but then sometimes horses
just can be
[__] horses and donkeys with all
their wonderful shapes and sizes and
capabil ities have coexisted with humans
for thousands of years and with all of
that charm and just a little bit of a
nibble I think that we want them around
us for thousands of years to
[Applause]
come parrots are known for their smarts
and for being cheeky and a little bit
naughty sometimes and yet here we are
inviting these feathered dinosaurs into
to our home but how much do we really
know about what's going on inside a
parrot's
brain no this is a pumpkin it's a
pumpkin for boo boo carellas yes it's a
pump God damn it you right on the ear as
[Music]
well it knows where the sensitive parts
are it's a smart birdie I like how she
turned from sweet as pumpkin pie into a
swearing
maniac
yeah why will a cocky bite you biting
behavior is used for all sorts of things
in the wild including play maintaining
hierarchy within the flock they can get
frustrated just like the rest of us
hormonal just like the rest of us and on
top of that they know how to get a
reaction from you right so if they do it
once and they get a really good reaction
they do it
again it's a learned behavior you know
how to need all your loved ones right
these are are really sensitive creatures
if you've got one in your home you've
got a big responsibility it's like
living with a toddler for like next 30
to 60 years of your life God damn
it okay this is
Nico having a temper tantrum getting
ready for a show and now she just said
why are you crying oh wow n are you
[Music]
done you are such a baby so we just
reinforced that behavior which is is
wonderful and people think I have a
crying baby out here I will show you
it's really
just what an
amazing mimic that bird
is this bird has identified that a
crying baby sound is a sound that
elicits a reaction from its humans this
is what I go through every day
it's not just mimicking random sounds
around it it's literally doing one that
gets the reaction that it wants the bird
wants and the bird wants
attention how Bird's mimic is pretty
impressive actually because they don't
have vocal cords like we do we have a
larynx and they have something that's
called a serx and how a parrot is
actually making these sounds is using
its singx but also its really dextrous
tongue that tongue is what's helping
make humanik sounds without having
humanlike apparatus to make them with
okay let's go and press these kids
[Music]
okay oh that cat is used to this parrot
pulling some
[__] the cat is thinking murderous
thoughts that parrot is about to be
naughty that's an African gray parrot
absolute stunner of a bird extremely
intelligent and also I understand
actually kept quite commonly as pets
particularly outside of Australia one
thing you can actually see in this video
is the fact that parrots have this
incredible ability to actually have two
toes facing forward and two toes facing
back and this means that they can grip
onto things sort of like how we use a
grip with a opposable thumb it means
they've got opposable digits so that's
why you can see them picking up stuff
and manipulating it with their beak
turning things around it's also why you
see this parrot torturing that cat cuz
it's able to go scritchy scritchy
scritchy and actually get a grasp on
that cat's head side note cats and birds
don't mix thank
you
[Music]
uh-oh angry cocky on the
loose oh it's just so methodical about
it as well it's like basically I'm here
and I'm going to B your
[__] that's basically the attitude of
this
[Music]
cocky oh yeah it's like looking you in
the eye while it's doing it as well
like so this is similar to our sulur
crested [__] a super intelligent
individual and if you invite one of
these into your life you're inviting
chaos into your life essentially because
it needs so much stimulus bless this
owner they've provided it with something
to do and that is destroy
[__] they really get some sort of
satisfaction from hearing textures and
feeling things in their environment
they're super sensory and literally like
a destruction company going through your
[Music]
house
that looks like we need to
put a PG rating on this one this is
adult content now that was an amazing
shot of the cocka tongue this is a
primary sensing organ of the coatu at
the very tip it's all about feeling but
the front is so incredibly Nimble they
can manipulate objects they can take a
seed and turn it in their mouth till
they get their beak and the seed in the
perfect place to Crunch down and open a
casing they've got a bite force of
something like 350 PSI that is enough to
cut through the skin and cause
significant bruising move over
nutcrackers we should all have [__] at
Christmas these wonderful Birds deserve
our respect and our admiration every
year there's more and more research that
shows how intelligent they are so if
you're out there being worried by AI
don't worry about the parrots
instead get him yeah get
him
members of the deer family include elk
and reindeer and moose and we think of
them as lovable sort of characters you
know like Bambi springing along and rudo
leading Santa sleigh and then there's
Bullwinkle a moose but what are the
dangers that wild deer actually pose
when they come into our
[Music]
neighborhoods
oh my God oh my God oh my God that's
going to be a complicated Insurance
claim oh my okay I like how that lady's
going back for a
handbag oh she's still having a cup of
tea oh the poor
thing the deer is clearly terrified in
this situation that big plate glass
window might have had Reflections and
there's looks like to be some Shrubbery
on the other side the deer might have
thought with the reflection of green
that this was actually an escape rot and
it found itself in a hairdressing Salon
[Music]
instead but what's it doing in a town in
broad daylight anyway well we keep on
building them where the animals are
living and on top of that we create
lovely Gardens right that have beautiful
grasses and lots of trees coming down so
the deer like to forage and graze on all
of these things and are attracted into
our
towns or it just wanted a crew cut oh my
God oh my God oh my
God I'm headed
in this Moosh
Trail okay spotted uh three balls two
were shedded and one still had both
sides oh
a I was flying my drone and he chook
himself and shook both antlers off wow
what an amazing thing to actually
capture that I sort of didn't realize
that it would happen so seamlessly but I
suppose that's logical what's actually
happening is their testosterone drops it
really bottoms out and that weakens the
calcium that joins the antlers onto the
skull and essentially one day when it's
weak enough they get up shake and their
antlers pop
off and this is one of the differences
right between antlers and horns horns
are bony protrusions that do not regrow
and are found on bow Vines and antlers
are these immensely beautiful intricate
bony protrusions that regrow every
season and are covered in velvet well at
least initially a covered in velvet and
what it actually does is helps blood
supply go all the way up through the
antler and they can grow really fast as
much as 20 cm in 9
days that's a growth
[Music]
spurt scared and trampling you is it
your moose it's not my moose but it's a
goddamn wild animal get the away from it
good advice you
idiots I hope that that new snails you
wish would hit me right
now G you guys
[Music]
idiots and he fell straight over yeah
get him get him get him I shouldn't be
mean and cynical but I really can't help
it have you guys not watched any of the
previous videos do not interfere with
wild
animals apparently in Alaska more people
are injured due to Moose incident than
be incidents and I think in part that's
due to the fact that people aren't
initially scared of moose so they act
like idiots moose are in general not
aggressive towards humans they really
don't want that much to do with us but
they will get protective in this case
protecting itself but they also might be
trying to protect their young yeah get
them get them someone once said that you
should treat all mood as if they're
serial killers with a loaded gun Don't
Go Near
him oo who's this coming along great Big
Moose walking by look at that
creature he's got one heck of a rack is
it appropriate to talk about someone's
rack like that look at that big Cruiser
it's bigger than that
car moose are the largest members of the
deer family they can weigh up to 600 180
kg they grow up to like 2 m
tall really good video to see the Bell
it's like this sort of fold of skin that
hangs below the moose's chin and makes
them extra handsome now he picking up a
little speed and going for a walk they
live in incredibly cold environments the
northern part of North America and right
across through Europe and Russia as well
and one of the ways which they cope with
the cold is actually by having hair that
is hollow like each individual strand of
hair is hollow and that creates a buffer
sort of like they were wearing a puffer
jacket oh that
sound
ooh oh no one of them just lost his
mobile
[Music]
phone so so what you see in is one of
the males trying to get an uphill
Advantage trying to make himself bigger
so that the one who's a little bit down
the slope has a disadvantage in the
fighting
situation I don't know where the jumping
into the Ute thing comes in though
that's just
[Music]
weird now they're just confused they're
like oh wait this is a bit
unusual male moose have a rutting season
it goes from September to October
roughly they'll be asserting themselves
over all the other males in the area and
on top of that the forehead skin gets
thicker this is to you know so they
don't get stabbed by someone else's
antler and their neck muscles get
something like two times thicker than
they normally are it's like they turn
into jimbros like overnight just all the
testosterone they have no chill no chill
at all in the rotting
season
look at that big Bruiser from their
massive size to their impressive
headwear and even their sort of grumpy
demeanor it's pretty clear that a moose
on the loose is a dangerous
[Music]
thing these five animals have some
behaviors that could potentially be
deadly but imagine what our
neighborhoods would be like if these
critters weren't there with us so
perhaps when it comes to deadliness what
actually needs to change is our
interactions with the animals that live
amongst us if you like this video then
maybe you should think about heading
over to the ABC science YouTube channel
and hitting subscribe because we are
always uploading videos about science as
diverse as astrophysics right through to
biology evolution you name it we've got
it ABC science
[Music]
YouTube